Speaker 1: and we started today talking about
Afghanistan, it's best we in that way as well.
Meghan McCain, Meghan McCain reemerged this
past weekend.
She's no longer on The View.
So she's got to turn to Twitter to get her
idiotic ideas out there to the world.
So she goes on Twitter this past weekend,
condemns all of these people saying we should
get out of Afghanistan, including the Biden
Biden administration saying this.
Here's her tweet.
Democrats like to wax poetic a lot about what
my dad would have done and said most of the
time, reinventing some weird fantasy of who
he was.
Let me tell you one damn thing.
He would be raging in public and a President
Biden about this withdrawal in Afghanistan
raging.
You know, Megan, you don't really need to
tell us that for two reasons, first of all,
nobody asked.
I'm just going to throw that out there first.
Literally, nobody asked a do you know why?
Because that's my second reason.
You don't need to telesis because nobody cares.
I'm sorry, I don't care if you think that
John McCain was a hero, if you think he was
a saint or if you think he was just another
conservative warhawk, which he was, I don't
care what the man would have thought about
the withdrawal of troops from Afghanistan.
Do you know why I don't care?
Because he's he's not a U.S. senator anymore,
he's he's not even alive.
So whether he supported it or was against
it, please, somebody explain to me how that
is relevant to anything on this planet.
Honestly, it's kind of the same argument that
Republicans oh, well, what would the founding
father think?
Who cares?
Who cares is the answer to that question.
Who cares what the founders would have thought?
Oh, the same people that thought a black slave
only counted as three fifths of a human being.
Yeah, I don't care what their opinion would
be of today's current political climate.
Oh, John McCain is not happy that we're pulling
troops out of Afghanistan.
Yeah, thanks for reminding us that the man
never met an international conflict that he
didn't immediately fall in love with.
That's what Meghan McCain was really doing
there, and this is why, folks, it really is
so dangerous when Democrats prop up these
individuals.
You know, we've seen it with Liz Cheney, we
saw with John McCain just because they hate
the same person, we didn't like Donald Trump,
that doesn't mean they're our friends.
That doesn't even mean there are allies.
John McCain, when he was still in the Senate,
still voted with Republicans, was it 90 percent
of the time?
Liz Cheney is over 90 percent of the time.
These people are not our friends, they are
not our allies just because we dislike the
same person, the enemy of my enemy is not
always my friend and we have to get that through
our heads.
And thank you, Meghan McCain, for taking the
time over the weekend to remind us that at
the end of the day, your father, God rest
his soul, was just another Republican who
wanted the U.S. to be involved in as many
international conflicts as humanly possible.
I want to thank David and the entire staff
at the David Pakman show for being so welcoming
to me here.
I will be with you once again tomorrow.
And until then, if for some reason you want
any more of me, you can find me on YouTube
at YouTube, dotcom, fair and balanced YouTube,
dotcom, the Ring of Fire, Twitter, Facebook
and Instagram at Faran Balanced.
Stay tuned for today's bonus show for the
members.
We've got some really great stories coming
up.
I am Ferron Cousins in for David Pakman.
Unidentified: Thanks for watching.